I think there's one thing here we can
all agree on the Internet has certainly
changed our lives so much so that
according to statistics,
three out of every four Americans can't
imagine life without music,
news,
shopping ads,
especially video services such as this
platform.
Youtube have huge amounts of data
flowing through them every day and it
just keeps growing.
Yeah,
that would be a plan for the Amazon is
giving the delivery guy spare key all
the apps,
gps video when classroom connecting with
another one continent in four time zones
away,
initials at the US State Department.
We're so concerned about the anti Muslim
videos that president trump retweeted
yesterday.
According to Cisco's estimates just in
the next five years alone,
the United States will multiply its
Internet traffic by three.
In fact,
in 2015,
the United States matched and surpassed
South Korea becoming the world's leader
per capita in data consumption.
Sure,
and of course the Internet's this great
virtual world is becoming more
integrated with on lives to making up an
increasingly larger share of our
economic activity.
So based on all of this,
you can probably imagine two things.
First,
the massive amounts of infrastructure
required by all of this consumption and
seconds,
how important Internet regulation is.
Well,
on the 14th of December 2017,
the federal communications commission of
the United States made a decision that
could well be described as historic due
to its transcendence and above all it's
controversy.
As you may know,
the Federal Communications Commission
decided by three votes against two to
end so-called net neutrality.
No one really is sure what will happen
now that the government has changed the
rules governing the worldwide.
This regulation was approved in 2015 at
the request of President Obama himself.
Yup,
you heard that right?
The regulation known as net neutrality
was born in 2015 within a short time
twisted the media and practically every
debate space was covered with this
message with facing the end of the
Internet.
As we know.
By the way,
this man is a GPI chairman of the United
States is federal communications
commission.
And this story is main protagonists or
we could say antagonist.
What we've decided is that we need to
restore the light touch market based
framework that started in the 19
nineties.
He is also probably one of the most
hated people on the Internet.
Well then maybe a couple of questions
that we need to answer here.
First,
what was this regulation fundamentally
about and seconds,
what does this change really mean?
What am I going to do in DC?
For two years,
CNC,
thousand and 15,
it was decided that the Internet would
pass from being regulated by the first
title of the communications locked to
the second title.
Well,
that doesn't really help us,
so what does that mean?
Well,
so you understand this better.
We could say that with this change,
the Internet,
that is the service provision starting
to be considered a public service and to
be strongly regulated by the government
in this case,
by the Federal Communications
Commission.
Ever since the Internet was created,
it's been organized around basic
principles of openness,
fairness,
and freedom.
This set of principles,
the idea of net and Trello,
it has unleashed the power of the
Internet and given innovators that
chance to thrive,
abandoning these principles would
threaten to end the internet as we know
it.
This is a regulation that among other
things prevented American operators such
as call Mecosta,
verizon,
or atnt,
from being able to on the one hand block
or slow down certain web spaces or
applications.
Traffic ends on the other,
prevents other content providers from
being preferred.
They should make it clear that whether
you use a computer,
phone,
or tablet,
Internet providers have a legal
obligation not to block or limit your
access to a website.
Imagine if a company decided to give
priority to Netflix over hbo or a
company that told spotify they needed to
pay if they wanted their customers to be
able to use their music services at high
school
speed
with this regulation,
companies at once able to charge fees
that didn't include access to a certain
service.
Imagine,
for example,
if a business wants at a high speed
connection that didn't consume netflix
prime video or hbo videos,
it wouldn't matter because with this
previous regulation that have to pay for
the entire service,
the operators wouldn't be able to offer
a rate without nationally
x
interview.
Uh,
this has all changed in the United
States.
Companies can now freely determine their
rates.
For example,
by offering an internet that doesn't
include being able to watch four k
videos.
Now,
this doesn't mean that they will,
but we will probably see different rates
and merge and it is basically this which
caused such controversy on the Internet.
It was so cool
virtual that only 107 out of the 239
Republican congressmen in the House of
Representatives have made their support
for this decision public.
But do you think this is really that
bad?
Do you think that the Internet will no
longer be the same?
Well,
in this video we want to show you the
various arguments for and against net
neutrality,
Internet threat.
Let's have a look at the dark side.
The reasons why net neutrality defenders
consider this change to be so negative,
these points aren't by fascinating,
so it won't take very long.
Those who detracts from the change that
the Republican Party promoted base their
position on two key arguments first that
given that operators can now charge
extra to both companies and customers,
the cost of the Internet will go up in
many small businesses and startups won't
be able to compete with the larger ones
because they won't be able to pay for
preferential access seconds because it
involves the ends of the freedom on
which the Internet was built.
Imagine if an operator decided to slow
down or even block access to a means of
communication.
Theoretically,
this could now happen.
Our Internet economy is the envy of the
world because it is open to all this
proposal.
Tears at the foundation of that
openness,
enhanced broadband providers.
The power to decide what voices to
amplify,
which sites we can visit,
what connections we can make,
and what communities we create.
It throttles access stalls,
opportunity and sensors.
Content.
Jessica Rosenworcel,
member of the Federal Communications
Commission bus
probably well versed on these arguments
already considering how often they've
been used in the media.
How do they view?
As you probably know that here are
visual politic.
We'd like to dig a little deeper so this
time we also wanted to take a look at
the net neutralities detractors side
saying,
well,
let's go for it
also cow.
Those who support ending so called net
neutrality have a clear perspective,
a very competitive market as the best
driver for innovation and ensuring good
customer service,
and one thing is certain.
Literally the Internet emerged.
It grew and developed fundamentally as a
free space without the regulation known
as net neutrality.
This is what Marc Andreessen,
netscape co founder and a key figure in
facebook's birth says on the subjects.
A pure net neutrality view is difficult
to sustain.
If you also want to have continued
investment in broadband networks.
If you have these pure net neutrality
rules,
Rican never charge a company like
Netflix.
Anything.
You're not ever going to get a return on
continued network investment,
which means you'll stop investing in the
network and it would not want to be
sitting here 10 or 20 years from now
with the same broadband speeds we're
getting today.
Marc Andreessen medscapes cofounder.
Yes.
This is one of the main criticisms they
have used to support this change.
Regulation discourages companies from
investing as we've seen before.
Internet traffic in the U,
s has grown from Mendocino and recent
years.
How surprisingly investments in
broadband infrastructure has stagnated
and even decreased in the same span of
time.
This obviously isn't normal and it fuels
one of the sectors,
main problems in the United States,
and that's a lack of competition in many
parts,
but of course,
if regulation
hinders and reduces the business's
potential profitability,
investment incentives are also
substantially reduced.
It's pretty logical,
right?
Another points claims by those
supporting the end to Obama's regulation
is that regulation could not only hurt
investments,
but it was also completely unnecessary.
Twenty years,
the Internet has thrived under the light
touch regulatory approach established by
President Clinton and a Republican
Congress.
This bipartisan framework with the
private sector to invest one point 5
trillion building communications
networks throughout the United States
and it gave us an internet economy that
became the envy of the world at Gte pie
according to the supporters in the 20
years before net neutrality that is
between 1995 and 2015.
Internet access only expanded and
improved in speed and quality.
Around this time.
The big digital companies we know today,
Google,
facebook,
Netflix,
Uber,
they emerged.
In fact,
it's funny,
but operators haven't really been the
big winners of the Internet's birth,
for example,
Alphabet Inc,
Google's parent company as a stock
market value that's quite a bit bigger
than the combined value of the three
largest telecommunications operators in
the United States.
That for net neutrality to is wonder why
change something that has worked so well
since its inception.
When is an operator restricted access to
a means of communication?
For example,
g mail in facts,
and this is what they use as an example.
The only time something similar happens
was when comcast trying to block peer to
peer connections to stop illegal
downloads.
In the end,
they have to back down because of bad
publicity and pressure from authorities,
but,
and this is the third point here,
less regulation does not mean anarchy.
In fact,
from now on in the United States,
the Internet will be regulated by the
powerful Federal Trade Commission,
which is in charge of the antitrust
policy,
and operators will also have to comply
with a strict transparency policy.
They will have to communicate any policy
that restricts or favors access speed to
any digital service.
There's the sky's not going to fall
down.
The FTC is going to be a vigorous cop on
the beat as it has been with respect to
the Internet providers.
John Liebowitz,
former Obama era,
FTC chairman,
well reform advocates proposed two
examples of how the market can evolve
without net neutrality.
One is the mobile phone markets,
which is much more competitive and it's
always been at the limits of legality.
The advocates say that in this extra
users have seen reductions in their
rates.
While the services have improved.
Nowadays,
there are promotions that include
unlimited access to services such as
Netflix without data consumption,
which clearly violates the spirits of
and the second example they usually give
is curiously founds in airlines,
particularly the company jet blue.
See,
these companies weren't subjected to
netsuite and you're trying to say,
and in spite of that and having an
agreement with Amazon's prioritize prime
video consumption on board,
they freely decided not to punish other
services such as HBO.
Our strategy for inflight Wifi is offer
the best service at the lowest cost to
as many passengers as possible,
so we're motivated to support all
content in a fair and neutral way.
Mark Dank Berg,
chief executive of Viasat Incorporated,
the satellite company that provides jet
blue's internet.
Now we are facing a very complex
question whether or not you agree with s
and you try to see both detractors and
opponents may have exaggerated it's
consequence just a bit,
but I think we're facing the end of the
incidents and we must not forget that
consumption tends to protect
freedom.
Yes.
Now it is true that large parts of the
United States,
do you have a serious competition?
Problem networks are only available from
one or two companies and there isn't a
market for choosing an operator,
but fortunately new technologies such as
five g,
which will make more competition
possible,
they seem to be just around the
personally.
I'm left with one wish and that's that
the internet remains as free as
possible,
but now it's your turn.
What do you think of the end of net
neutrality?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoyed this video.
Please hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine and as always,
thank you for watching,
connecting with another one continent
and four time zones away.
Officials at the US State Department,
we're so concerned about the.